Presuasion is the process of arranging
for an audience to agree with your
message before they encounter it.
Now,
that might sound like some form of
magic,
but it's not.
It's established science.
Very often we can use priests,
waist live tactics,
even other kinds of influence tactics on
ourselves to increase the likelihood
that we will reach our goals,
that we will obtain the outcomes that we
hope for in a particular situation.
There's research,
for example,
to show that if you depict for people an
image of a runner winning a race,
they become more achievement oriented
and actually achieved their goal to a
greater extent while that runner is in
the background.
There's another piece of research,
a followup research that shows that if
you depict for people an image of
Rodin's,
the thinker,
you know that the statute,
they become more analytic and
deliberative and they're more likely to
solve problems,
difficult,
complex problems that they're faced
with.
So this is something we can do to
ourselves.
If we have a task that requires a lot of
energy and motivation.
Put a picture of a runner winning a race
in the corner of your computer screen
where you will see that cue there while
you're performing the task.
If you're analyzing a budget perhaps or
developing some plan that requires a lot
of strategic thinking,
put a picture of the thinker there and
you're more likely to achieve that
particular goal.
The thing is we get to control the cues
in our environment that send us in
directions that are likely to be
successful for the particular task we
have at hand.
When writing my book presuasion,
I dedicated it to my grandchildren and
there was something I did for myself to
pre swayed me to make that the best
possible book I could develop and
produce.
It was to put the following image in my
mind of each of my grandchildren who are
young right now.
Here's the image.
When they're old enough to read it,
I've left a copy with their parents for
each of them,
and I want their parents to give them
the book and say,
you see this?
This book was dedicated to you.
Will it better be a good book?
It better be the highest quality book I
can arrange,
and so while I was writing that book,
there was a corner,
there was a coroner,
photograph of my grandkids on the screen
of my computer.
That picture kept me focused on quality.
No short cuts allowed.
This is for my grandkids.
It better be the best book I can
possibly generate.
When I first started investigating the
influence process,
I actually became a spy of sorts.
I went undercover to all of the major
professions of our society dedicated to
getting us to say yes and I took
training.
I enrolled in the training programs of
salespeople,
fundraisers,
recruiters,
public relations specialists and so on
to see what were the techniques that
we're working most
widely across the range,
the broadest range of these influence
strategies of these influence approaches
and what.
What I found was interesting in that
there was a particular kind of
practitioner within those influenced
professions who rose to the top.
Almost invariably.
It wasn't the individual who spent most
of his or her time crafting the message
that they sent.
Although that was important to them.
It was that they crafted what they said
and did immediately before they
delivered their message.
That was the differentiator between the
average scores and the aces of each
profession.
Those people who were the highest
achievers were priests,
waders,
they,
they acted like expert gardeners.
They knew that it didn't matter how good
this seed that you had might be if you
didn't prepare the earth for it first,
it wasn't going to bear fullest fruit.
So they cultivated the earth.
They,
they,
they pretreated the ground,
and before they planted their seed with
their message,
they did something that caused the
recipients of their message to have a
positive state of mind before they
encountered the message itself.
The interesting question is,
how do you go about cultivating the
earth?
How do you arrange for people to be in a
frame of mind that is conducive to the,
uh,
the message that you wanted to send?
Um,
it is to recognize,
first of all,
what is the central element of your
message?
What is the feature of your message that
would make it most wise for people to
accept your offer?
Right?
And then you take that dimension and go
to the moment before you deliver your
message and give draw people's attention
to that idea,
to that dimension.
Let me give you an example.
There was a study done by an online
furniture store.
They had a furniture that was
comfortable.
They also had lower and furniture that
was attractive because it was
inexpensive and they did an experiment.
They send half of the visitors to their
site to a background depiction of clouds
on the landing page of a wallpaper of
their site.
So the landing page had fluffy clouds on
the back background.
Those people read it comfort as the most
important factor in buying a sofa.
They spent more time searching for
comfort related information inside the
site and they preferred comfortable
furniture to purchase.
The other half of the visitors were sent
to a site that had as its background,
wallpaper,
pennies,
coins,
money,
right?
Those people rated cost as the most
important feature for them for
purchasing a sofa.
They searched for price related
information and they purchased more
inexpensive furniture.
They preferred to purchase more
inexpensive furniture as a consequence.
So you can see that what was the central
dimension of the message,
it could be comfort or it could be cost,
could be installed in a customer's mind
ahead of time,
which caused them to see that dimension
as more important,
to search for information relative to it
and to act on the basis of a product
that gave them that dimension in a
prioritized way.
It could be cost,
it could be clouds.
Here was the interesting thing about
that study.
For me,
almost no one recognized that they had
been influenced by the background
wallpaper.
It flew under the radar.
That means that this is something that's
not only powerful,
it's also something that we have to deal
with in a as as as communicators in an
ethical way,
because we've got some things that are
going to move people in our direction
without them even recognizing or taking
into account that we're moving them in
their,
in,
in their direction,
in our direction.